good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today is scp-4505
object class
safe
special containment procedures
the
scp-4505 collection is housed in
reliquary site 14 for storage and
display a minimum of three foundation
archivists are to facilitate appropriate
care and study of the collection any
personnel involved in the research and
or containment of anomalous artwork may
be granted gallery access for
educational purposes pending the
completion and approval of employee
access request rs14 ea3 scp-4505
items featured in the observation
gallery are to be rotated on a
bi-monthly basis
description
scp-4505 is the collective designation
for 265 safe class anomalous artworks
created between the 14th and 17th
centuries as part of the cultural
movement known as the renaissance the
original 130 pieces were previously
listed as individual scp objects until
their eventual consolidation and
sub-designation under the parent number
of scp-4505
as part of the sek object class
initiative in 1914 additional works have
been acquired and added to the
collection in subsequent years
the collection is available as an
educational resource for foundation
employees
the following is a truncated list of
artifacts consolidated under
scp-4505 staff members involved in the
containment of any of
scp-4505 item must familiarize
themselves with the entire collection
before beginning work see anomalous
history of art volumes 23-24
note that items are numbered in order of
acquisition not creation
title pieta serial number scp-4505-035
artist tondino year 1623
description
animate marvel sculpture depicting the
madonna weeping over the deceased christ
inspired by michelangelo's sculpture of
the same name tondino's piece diverges
from the original by posing the madonna
knelt over her prone son the figures are
non-sentient and unresponsive to stimuli
the madonna shakes her sun and pantomime
sobs but produces no sound the deceased
christ is not independently animate and
makes no movements other than those
instigated by the madonna's physical
interactions both figures feature
realistic anatomy visually emulating the
elasticity and malleability of soft
tissue within the context of the piece's
internal action however physical contact
from external sources will interact with
the figures as solid marble
several historical records pertaining to
the piece describe an incident wherein a
child's fingers were severed after
playfully inserting them into the
madonna's mouth these accounts are
supported by recent internal imaging of
the madonna's stomach which has revealed
the presence of 11 fingers from no fewer
than three different parties as well as
a large amount of coinage in various
denominations
title the judgment of the unrighteous
serial number scp-4505-089
artist unknown year 1434.
description bronze door with sculpted
relief panels depicting various scenes
in hell as described in dante allegri's
divine comedy anomalous phenomena occur
when it has been viewed by a person who
has recently committed an act deemed
sinful by 15th century catholic doctrine
subjects who meet the above criteria
will experience a cognitohazard-induced
hallucination wherein they are
surrounded by indistinct red red-hooded
figures these figures are often observed
holding and consuming the severed heads
of cephalophoric saints effects subside
entirely within 20 to 30 minutes
title cardinal del monte serial number
scp-4505-118
artist unknown year 1554
description
life-size oil portrait on canvas with
accompanying section of wall the
painting depicts in a kenzo kiachi del
monte adopted nephew and possible lover
of pope julius iii
the painting was removed from the papal
palace multiple times after the death of
julius iii in 1555 but always reappeared
in the same place the following day
attempts to destroy the piece were
similarly undone after several weeks
effort it was decided that the entire
section of wall where the painting hung
was to be detached from the building and
removed from the premises
title the elation of saint paul serial
number scp-4505-122
artist gene brodel year 1495
description
oil on panel the painting features an
anomalous chiroscuro effect which causes
the lighting of the scene to change over
a 24-hour period with the movement of
the sun moon and stars progressing in
real time
the rest of the scene which is otherwise
static features paul the apostle
standing before a crowd in what is
presumably the artist's interpretation
of a jewish synagogue all figures are
dressed in italian formal wear common to
the period
paul is posed as though preaching to the
assembly albeit with a thick stream of
honey pouring from his mouth the heads
of doves protrude from where his eyes
would normally be found and his fingers
expel a milky substance which pulls
beneath him several bystanders are
gathered around the puddle using their
hands to drink several sources suggest
that the surreal imagery corresponds to
paul's martyrdom as described in the
golden legend
title lorenzo di medici serial number
scp-4505-164
[Music]
artist unknown year 1502
description an oil painting depicting
the body of lorenzo di medici in an
advanced state of decomposition it is
one of the earliest known attempts at
crafting a fully animate and intelligent
reproduction of an existing human within
a two-dimensional space due to split
opinions regarding the sanctity of the
piece it remained out of view in deep
storage at the medician academy of
occult arts until 1944.
during the second world war numerous and
artworks were disguised as traditional
pieces and entrusted to the mfaa for
protection which subsequently allowed
pieces such as
scp-4505-164 to be discovered and
acquired by foundation resources see an
anomalous history of art volume 81
lorenzo allegedly commissioned the
painting after he was drawn in by the
artist's offers of immortality the
artist whose identity remains unknown
succeeded in creating a painted likeness
of lorenzo that could hold conversations
with viewers and move within the
confines of its 126 by 104 centimeters
surface as if it were a
three-dimensional space
however the depiction of lorenzo proved
to be more life-like than intended and
perished due to starvation several weeks
after the painting was completed before
its death it reportedly subsisted on a
bowl of fruit the artist had painted in
the foreground as well as an animate
bird painted on a windowsill
title saint peter serial number
scp-4505-201
artist unknown year 1518.
description
animate bronze sculpture created under
the patronage of pope leo the tenth the
piece was originally envisioned as a
living idealization of saint peter that
could interact with the public and
educate them on matters of biblical
history and catholic ideology
though the project was initially
successful the piece began to question
its own existence and subsequently
developed a sense of individual identity
eventually culminating in a public
renunciation of christian belief the
church quickly removed the statue from
public display records indicate the
piece was scheduled to be destroyed but
for unknown reasons was instead gagged
and buried in an unmarked plot and
remained there until it was accidentally
discovered by a construction company
nearly five centuries later
the figure has since been taken into
foundation care and given extensive
counseling though it still displays
severe mental instability and social
impediment as a consequence of its
prolonged isolation a psychiatric
evaluation carried out in 1986 can be
found in chapter 6 of an annotated
history of art-based life by gertrude
blau
the figure can be violent but poses
negligible threat to viewers as it
cannot leave it 0.7 by 0.7 meter base
title the mercy stoop serial number
scp-4505-213
artist agnolio saloni year 1441
description
a plain gold basin set into an ivory
stand with various scenes from the
crucifixion of jesus carved along its
circumference any liquid poured into the
basin gradually transmutes into blood
over the course of 10 to 12 minutes
originally created to hold holy water
the piece showed no anomalous properties
until the artist's death in 1446. it was
acquired from an unknown vendor in 1961
by the horizon initiative for its
apparent eucharistic properties the
group presented it as a gift to the
foundation in 1992 after a scientific
examination revealed the transmuted
blood to be from a male lipicine horse
title the lamentation of saint
bartholomew serial number 4505-254
artist garcikaty year 1576
description
an unfinished oil painting on wood
depicting saint bartholomew in the
process of being flamed from the heels
up the piece emits constant
vocalizations of pain which intensify in
response to physical or auditory stimuli
no other animate characteristics have
been observed
a notable degree of attention has been
paid to the details in bartholomew's
exposed musculature possibly influenced
by anatomical drawings created by
andreas vesalius in the years prior the
figures carrying out bartholomew's
flaying are dark and indistinct it is
not known if this was a creative
decision or merely a consequence of the
painting's incomplete state the skin
removed from bartholomew's legs has been
twined and knotted into a noose the
posing of the figures suggests that the
noose is drawn closer to bartholomew's
head with every inch of skin peeled from
his back
title trinity of the red court serial
number scp-4505-265
artist data restricted year 1586
description
oil on canvas christ is suspended in a
dark void hanging by the neck from a
rope which extends out of frame those
who view the painting for a prolonged
period of time will gradually notice
changes in its content
the effect resets after the viewer has
looked away for more than 10 seconds
changes are consistent among different
viewers and viewing sessions and occur
in the same sequence
lacerations appear across the deceased
christ's body
a gesture is added to the lower left
corner of the painting pointing at the
deceased christ
young children appear behind the gesture
in a long line that extends into the
darkness
a hooded figure mounted on a horse is
added to the bottom right corner of the
painting the heels on the rider's shoes
end in blood-stained spikes
numerous puncture wounds appear on the
side of the horse's body
heavy chains appear around the hooded
figure binding its arms to its torso
the deceased christ raises his arms
toward the jester and ryder see
archetypes in anart chapter 5 king clown
and counsel
christ's expression changes to a broad
grin
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening if indeed you still are
and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
ian j alsop
zargaran
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
savanity
kristoff kozak slesak
hms lily
the almighty fish
gav the clumsy containment specialist
spooky aqua
pure osmium
scio dio damnares
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
drew peacock
eric corbich
longinus
james saba
and
njvojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the vulgan
thank you
you